>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Steven Levingston: Eric Weiner
is a wanderer, a searcher for God,
for genius, for happiness.
Fortunately for us he takes
us on his journeys and we get
to see his humor, his
curiosity, his deep intelligence.
In his book, Man Seeks God, he went
in search of the divine traveling
to Nepal to try Buddhism, to the
Bronx to mix with the Franciscans,
to China to take in the Daoists,
and to Israel to plunge
into the Kabbalah.
In his search for happiness, Weiner,
again traveled far and wide seeking
to discover the happiest
place on the planet.
Perhaps, not surprisingly, he found
that happiness is not a
place but a state of mind.
And the things that people normally
think bring us happiness do not.
If money were the key, why do people
living in humble circumstances
in Latin America say
that they're very happy.
In his latest book, The Geography
of Genius, Weiner sets off
on another worldly quest to
find the wellspring of genius.
And he comes to the realization
that genius is not necessarily what
we have always imagined it to be.
Of course, we have our
solitary tortured geniuses,
van Gogh, Mozart, da Vinci.
But Weiner looks beyond the
individual to the times and places
that gave rise to --
gave birth to genius.
And he discovers that genius
often arose after a period
of hardship, chaos, and uncertainty.
In many cases a mixing of different
cultures was a contributing factor.
Before he combed the
world as an author,
Weiner was foreign
correspondent for NPR reporting
for more than 30 countries.
Now, please join me in
welcoming Eric Weiner.
[ Applause ]
>> Eric Weiner: Wow.
I think I may have to add a chapter
to my book about the geography
of genius include this room.
Because I sense a lot
of genius out there.
Steve, thank you for
that great introduction.
I think you did neatly
sort of sum up what I do.
Because it's not always easy to
explain to people what I do when,
you know, you have to fill out
the forms and put occupation,
I usually write philosophical
traveler.
This is -- confuses
people at the IRS
and makes you subject
to audits, you know.
But that really is what
I'm doing is I'm looking
for the intersection
of place and idea.
And I've always been a traveler
and I've always done my
best thinking on the road.
Ever since I was five years old and
I ran away from home, true story,
and I got a good mile
and-a-half away from home
and would have made it to
wherever it was I was trying to get
to had Baltimore County
Police not decided to,
I thought a bit impetuously,
intervene with my little adventure.
But ever since I've been
wandering and as Steve said looking
at big ideas, like happiness, like
spirituality and now like genius,
not just any ideas, ideas where
I feel that the role of place
or geography in the biggest sense
of the word is often overlooked.
And I do think that is the case
with genius because there are a lot
of theories, slash,
myths surrounding genius.
It's a big word; right?
It comes to us like so
many words from Latin.
But the Latin notion of genius was
that it was not something
you achieved;
it was something that
accompanied you.
A sort of presiding spirit or
deity that followed you around.
You had your genius take --
you know, sort of travel
with you everywhere.
And today it means
lots of things; right?
It might mean someone
with a really high IQ
or someone who's a
really know-it-all.
That's not the definition
I'm working with.
I believe that genius
is not a know-it-all.
A genius is a see-it-all,
someone who sees connections.
Someone who is creative really.
Creative genius.
But where do these
creative geniuses come from?
Well, myth No.
1, and I use the term myth in sort
of the Joseph Campbell
sense is it's something
that can be very empowering
and perhaps partially true
but not 100 percent true.
Myth No. 1 is that
geniuses are born.
They just pop out of the
womb fully brilliant.
Think of Mozart as sort of the
poster child for this theory.
You know, playing the violin at age
three and composing at age eight,
it must have been that he
was born that way; right?
Ignoring the fact that his
father Leopold Mozart was one
of premier violin instructors
and musicians of the time
and that he was growing
up in a very musical era
in a very musical city of Salzburg.
So I don't believe that
genetics accounts for as much
as we think of the genius puzzle.
And the second myth, again in
quotes, is that geniuses are made
through hard work; right?
It's the 10,000 hour theory which
you may be familiar with, you know.
Put in at least 10,000 hours of
work over ten years and you have
at least a chance of achieving
excellence if not genius.
Well, I know a lot of hard
working people in North Korea
with good genes who
aren't achieving genius.
And there have been plenty of
hard working women in ages past
who did not achieve
the status of genius
because they weren't recognized and
they weren't given the opportunity.
I don't think genetics and
hard work alone explains it.
In fact, I began to
think about this.
So I thought, well, what
if geniuses are not born,
what if they're not made,
what if they're grown.
What if it's actually in the soil.
Think about, you know,
growing an apple tree; right?
You need to have the
seed, good quality seed.
You need to put in some
hard work planting it.
That's the work part.
But you need to have the right soil
or you're not going
to have an apple tree.
So, in fact, as I investigated this,
if you look at a map of the world
over the course of history and
you were to plot the appearance
of geniuses, of the
Beethovens and the Einsteins
and others throughout
history, you know,
you wouldn't find them appearing
randomly, you know, one in Belgrade,
one in Vienna, one in Alexandria,
two in Alexandria, I don't know.
But you don't -- what you find is
that they are in these groupings.
Genius clusters I call them; right?
Certain places at certain
times have just been very good
at producing brilliant
minds and good ideas.
And the question is why.
What was in the water back then
and for selfish reasons we want
to know can we bottle it; right?
I'm interested in the history
but it's sort of applied history.
What are the lessons for us today.
So I came up with a list of
seven golden ages ranging
from ancient Athens
to Silicon Valley.
Some of them were pretty well known
to most of my readers, I think,
such as Athens during
the Classical period,
Florence during the Renaissance.
Others were maybe not as
well known such as Edinburgh
in the 18th century in the time of
the -- the Scottish Enlightenment.
Or Vienna which had a rare double
dip of genius which I'll talk
about both in Mozart and
Beethoven's time and then
in Freud's time around 1900.
And some of the places
I chose are really
for most readers a terra
incognita I would say.
Hangzhou china in the 13th century,
an amazing, amazing genius cluster
that we don't, in the West
at least, know much about.
Or Calcutta.
Yes, Calcutta in India in the
late 19th, early 20th century home
to the Bengal Renaissance where more
books were published than any city
in the world except for London and
produced the first non-Westerner
to win the Nobel Prize for
literature, Rabindranath Tagore.
And then I bring the book home to
Silicon Valley because I wanted
to bring it home, and
I wanted to bring it
to a current place of genius.
So word about what the academics
would call methodology and what I
like to call how I do stuff.
I do -- here's my sort
of philosophy of travel.
Read about a place before you go
there but don't read too much.
I would read lots of histories
before I would go somewhere.
But I didn't want to read other
contemporary authors accounts
because I wanted to have
a fresh take on places.
I also am a loiterer.
I will go some place
and spend more time
than I think I need to spend there.
Now the challenge for me in this
book was writing about the past.
In my previous books I've written
about contemporary India
or Bhutan or Iceland.
The past, it's been said,
is a foreign country.
They do things differently there.
And it's true.
So the challenge was to make
these places come alive.
I suppose I could have written
this entire book without leaving,
say the Library of Congress.
But that's not the way I roll.
I really -- I feel because people
have asked me that question, like,
well, do you really
think you need to go
to Athens and the answer is yes.
I think to walk in the footsteps
of Socrates or Plato or Aristotle
and to experience the place they
experienced is vitally important.
So I want to give you a
quick world tour of some
of the places I visited,
what I found,
and then open it up to questions.
So I start in Athens.
And Athens is a mystery; okay.
It's a mystery because of all the
places to produce so much genius
in such a short period of time, you
wouldn't necessarily choose Athens
because remember there
were hundreds and hundreds
of these Greek city states.
Hundreds of Greeces, you
know, little microcultures.
And Athens did not
have the most going
for it compared to
these other places.
So I'm just going to read a
little section to give you a sense
of my task, what I was up to, and
what I found out about Athens.
As I said "the past
is a foreign country;
they do things differently there.
Yes, they do.
And unfortunately this
particular foreign country known
as ancient Greece has
extremely tight border controls.
It doesn't take kindly to
interlopers such as me.
Yet, if I'm going to solve
the Athenian mystery,
the past is exactly
where I need to be.
What to do?
Squint. That was the
advice of a friend back home
when I had mentioned my
plans to visit Athens.
I laughed it off but now I realize
it's actually a smart tactic.
Sometimes we can see more
by narrowing our field
of view than by expanding it.
The zoom lens reveals as much as
the wide angle and sometimes more.
Don't squint too much,
Aristotle warns."
I should say that Aristotle is
the name of my guide in Athens.
Talk about a wonderful
piece of serendipity.
It's kind of burden, though,
when your name is Aristotle.
And I really thought at
first, well, this is great.
And he's like, you
know, it's not so great.
People assume great
wisdom on his part.
And he's plenty smart but, you
know, you don't want that name.
"If I could time travel, he
says, to Athens circa 450 BC,
I'd probably be disappointed.
The great Athens, the cradle of
Western civilization, the birthplace
of science, philosophy, and so
much else we hold dear was a dump.
The streets were narrow and dirty.
The houses constructed of wood
and sun dried clay were so flimsy
that robbers gained
entry by simply digging.
In fact, the ancient Greek word
for robber means literally one
who tunnels through walls.
As a time traveler I would
definitely notice the noise,
vendors hawking their wares
at the Agora, a flute,
a lute rather screeching off key.
But what would grab my attention
and not let go is the stench.
People relieved themselves in
the courtyard of their own home
or even right in the streets
where the mess would sit
until a slave sluiced it away.
Conditions were such that as
historian Jacob Burckhardt put it,
no sensible and peaceful person
of our day would want
to live under that."
And he wrote those words by
the way in the 19th century.
So this is one of the great myths
of these places of genius is
that they're paradise, that
they're really nice places.
They're not.
They're difficult places.
I really believe that one
of the keys to creativity is
that we need constraints.
We need something to push against.
And paradise if it does exist
and I hope it does is probably the
least creative place in the universe
because you don't have that
need to create something.
You don't have that
something to push against.
You know, there was one
very interesting study done
by a psychologist where
he gave two groups
of people an assignment
to build a collage.
But one group was given a very
limited number of materials
and limited number of options of how
they can work with these materials.
And the other was given
a whole bunch
of material and lots of options.
And it was that first group
with the greater constraints
who produced the more creative,
as judged by a panel, collages.
We need something to push against.
And we need that sort of messiness,
I don't know about the stench,
but the messiness that you had
in Athens because creativity
and creative genius
is not a neat process.
There is a messiness to it
and that's why you
often see relationship
between chaos and creativity.
If you think about it, if you're
going from the old way of thinking
to the new way of thinking,
you need to pass
through an intermediate stage.
That intermediate stage is chaos.
A neuroscientist named Walter
Freeman studied the brains
of rabbits.
No rabbits were harmed
in these experiments.
I just want you to know because I
always feel uncomfortable with that.
But he hooked up their
little rabbit brains to EEGs
and he introduced them to odors.
And some odors they
were quite familiar with
and other odors they
were new to them.
Well, when they saw a familiar
odor, the EEG had a regular readout.
When they were introduced
to an unfamiliar odor,
they saw a very chaotic
state on the EEG.
And Freeman called that very
interestingly the I don't
know state.
And that I don't know state is
essential for creative genius
and it's essential that these
places nurture it, cultivate it.
One thing I should add about
all these places they have
in common is they're
almost all cities.
If it takes a village to raise a
child as the African proverb goes,
it takes a city to make a genius.
I won't say to raise a genius
but to cultivate a genius.
Because cities provide
the opportunities;
cities provide the audience
which is hugely important.
And a city like Athens
had the one single trait
that psychologists have identified
as the most important trait
for creative people and I
would argue for creative places
and that is this, openness
to experience.
Openness to experience.
And the manifestation of that
in ancient Athens was
the Port of Piraeus.
And they went out and
they sailed and here's one
of the dirty little secrets
about the ancient Greeks.
They mooched.
They were tremendous moochers.
They borrowed ideas
statuary from the Egyptians
and mathematics from elsewhere.
As Plato said though what the Greeks
borrow, very nice way of putting it,
or steal from foreigners
they perfect.
And there's nothing wrong
with that, you know.
As the historian Will
Durant said something
that at first I found disturbing
and later I've come to embrace.
He said, nothing is
new but the arranging.
Nothing is new but the arranging.
At first as a writer,
I thought, oh, shoot.
Well, I've got nothing new to say.
But then I realized there's
great beauty in the arranging,
you know, and the rearranging.
You can probably find every word
that I have in this book somewhere
out there in other books scattered
around the world but not arranged
in the particular way
I've arranged them.
So genius is about the art of
stealing and borrowing as well.
And just -- this is going to be a
quick whirlwind tour but let's talk
about another well known place
which is Florence; right?
A couple interesting things about
Florence in the Italian Renaissance.
One is that it was born
out of catastrophe.
That the Italian Renaissance which
started in Florence started not more
than a few decades after the
outbreak of the bubonic plague known
as the black death which was
horrible, which was terrible,
which should not be
wished on any society.
But it had this effect of shaking up
the culture of making it less rigid.
And some historians believe,
and I subscribe to this,
that it was that shaking
up that ultimately led
to the flourishing known
as the Renaissance.
And the other interesting thing
about the Italian Renaissance is
the role that money played in it.
Now we have this very romantic
notion of this starving artist.
Forget it.
The starving artist doesn't
produce anything except his own --
or her own misery.
They're always worried
about their next meal.
So some degree of money is required.
And this is where patronage
comes into play.
And it took the form of one
particular family, the Medici who --
it's not enough just
to throw money around.
You have to know what you're doing
and they knew what they were doing.
And there's a great story about
Lorenzo Medici who was known
as Lorenzo the Magnificent.
I think it said it
on his business card.
I think that's just how he went by.
And one day he is -- he's walking
outside the sort of palace grounds
in the Medici gardens and he
sees this young stone cutter
who can't be more than 14
years old working on a sort
of rudimentary statute
of a fawn, a Roman deity.
And Lorenzo, who's getting
up there in age by now,
says well that's pretty good, kid.
But, you know, it's an older fawn
and it's teeth though are new.
When you're an older man like
me your teeth don't look so new.
And he walked away.
Comes back the next day Lorenzo does
and notices the kid has
perfected the teeth and put
in a little tooth decay and
really created something special.
And -- and --
Lorenzo is sort of on
this spot, takes a chance.
Makes an investment in that kid
and says you come live with me,
basically live with me, become
a part of my family essentially.
I'm going to give you the best
access to teachers and to materials
and the highest challenges.
And it was a very wise investment
because today that kid goes
by just one name usually,
Michelangelo.
Now we think of Michelangelo
as the genius, he's well known.
Lorenzo the Magnificent less so.
But you can argue that
without Lorenzo
and his patronage there would be
no Michelangelo and you can argue
that the real genius was Lorenzo.
You could also argue as I would
that the real genius was the city
of Florence and their appreciation
and their willingness
to make bets like that.
Another Michelangelo story
is Pope Julius II was looking
to have some ceiling work
done on the Sistine Chapel.
So he sends out bids to
contractors essentially.
But he chose Michelangelo which was
-- now we look back and say, well,
that's such an obvious choice.
It wasn't at the time, you know.
Michelangelo was mainly
a statute maker.
He was a, you know,
a sculptor rather.
He was not -- he was not
so much of a painter.
But that, I think, is
something essential
and something we've lost a bit on.
That's taking, making a big bet
on someone whose not the
exact fit for the job.
Think of how many jobs today, like,
we look to hire someone who's done
that exact same job previously.
But the Pope who was a Medici
from the family took a bet
on Michelangelo and it
paid off tremendously.
Other places.
Hung jo China.
So in the 13th century, you
know, Europe is pretty backward.
You know, they're picking fleas out
of each other's hair and wondering
when the Dark Ages are
ever, ever going to end.
This is just going on too long.
But at the time Hangzhou
is a flourishing city
of a million people,
you know, or more.
And it is just taking off.
And they're sailing ships
that are unlike anything
that Europeans have done.
And it's ruled, no joke,
by a group of poet emperors
and that's nice, you know.
It's, you know, wouldn't the world
be a better place if it was run
by poet politicians
or poet philosophers.
So and the striking thing is that
there's sort of a top down approach.
This is often the way China works is
that people, a Chinese person said,
well, we play follow the leader.
And I thought really?
Well, if you think about it
when your emperor's a poet,
it's going to filter down.
So there's a tremendous
amount of poetry and writing
and scientific research going on.
And it has the characteristic
of all of these places of genius
and that is that it is
extremely interdisciplinary.
People are crossing boundaries.
So I want to share with you just
one section where I'm looking
at the work of somebody
named Su Dong-Po.
Now in addition to being a
paint, poet and a painter's,
Su is much still revered in
Hangzhou by the way was a governor
and an accomplished engineer.
His best known project
was a causeway
that traversed West Lake
and still does today.
Su was a renaissance man 300
years before the Renaissance.
So as I step out of the small
museum where I'm admiring his work
to this bright sky in
the city of Hangzhou,
I find myself wondering why aren't
there more people like that today?
Why must we sequester our ambitions?
I answer my own question by
imagining what would happen
if a poly-man like Su Dong-Po walked
on to a modern college campus.
Is it literature you're
interested in, Mr. Su?
Oh, well, then please see
the School of Humanities.
Oh, what's that?
You're a painter?
Well, please drop by the
Department of Fine Arts.
I'm sorry.
It's engineering that
piques your interest?
Well, we have an excellent
school for that too.
But I want to do it all, says Su.
I'm sorry Mr. Su, we
can't help you there.
Please return when you've
clarified your career objectives.
Meanwhile if you like I can direct
you to mental health services.
You see, we don't often question
the rationale for specialization.
Of course, there was a lot -- there
was less specialization back then,
a friend told me at a dinner party.
The world was less complicated.
It was. But I would argue that
the world was less complicated
because there was less
specialization.
A specialist is encouraged,
rewarded,
for parsing his chosen field
into smaller and smaller morsels,
then building high walls
around these tiny bits,
a narrow outlet naturally follows.
We mourn the death of the
Renaissance man and women.
Oblivious to the blindingly
obvious fact that we killed him
and we continue to do so
every day on college campuses
and in corporate offices
across the land.
And I think that is one reason why
we are arguably, and it's arguably,
seeing fewer creative
breakthroughs today.
Because as I said before the
genius is not a know-it-all;
the genius is a see-it-all.
There were physicists
during the time of Einstein
who knew more physics than
Einstein did, but they weren't able
to make those connections
that he was able to make.
And what you see -- let's time
travel a few hundred years past
Hangzhou to Vienna now of 1900.
And this -- this was an
incredible flourishing.
You had the art movement
with Gustav Klimt.
You had physicists like Ernst Mach.
You had philosophers.
You had writers like
Arthur Schnitzler
and you had Sigmund Freud.
So what often happens when
you have sparks flying in lots
of different directions is a
fire of creativity ignites.
So if you're Sigmund Freud and
you're sitting there in Vienna
and you see a new art movement,
the Secessionist movement
and you see new developments of the
world of philosophy and mathematics,
you start to think on an unconscious
level that as Freud would put it,
then why not in my field too.
Because creativity is contagious.
There is a contagion effect.
And that's why I think it's
very important for places
like Silicon Valley to not
just do technology; right?
But to have a thriving art
scene there for selfish reasons.
In addition to art being
beautiful and wonderful, is it --
actually it's going to
help the technology field
because these lines we think
are so solid are not, in fact.
So a couple words about
Silicon Valley
and then I do want to
take your questions.
It was probably the hardest
chapter for me to write to be honest
because it's not done yet.
There's no period at the end of it.
And people are familiar with it
more than they are with Hangzhou
so they think they know what
makes Silicon Valley tick.
I went there with a
completely open mind.
I did not talk to technology
people because I don't --
not exclusively because Silicon
Valley actually has very little
to do with technology.
I really believe that.
The product is technology, yes.
But the process is cultural.
Right. So I hung out
with anthropologists
and there are some
anthropologists there who are sort
of the Margaret Meads of Silicon
Valley who look at the locals
and their strange customs
and what they do.
And what Silicon Valley is very good
at is it actually resembles a lot
of these ancient golden
ages in some ways.
You have that mooching going
on, that borrowing ideas.
Actually very little,
relatively little is invented
in Silicon Valley.
Not the cell phone which was
invested in a suburb of Chicago.
Not venture capital
which came from New York.
But there is a system in Silicon
Valley for let's just say for --
what's the hot word these
days, curating these ideas.
So as much as places of genius
are magnets for good ideas,
they also need to be
colanders to sift
out the good from the bad; right?
So Jonas Salk two time Nobel prize
winner, no slouch, was once asked
by a young student, you know,
Dr. Salk, how do you come
up with so many good ideas?
He said, well, it's easy.
I come up lots of ideas and I
throw away the bad ones; right?
That element of discernment
is hugely important
and often overlooked.
We think that, you know, in
order to have a tolerant --
in order to have a creative
atmosphere, you need to be tolerant.
Well, yeah, you need to
be tolerant but you need
to be discerning in that tolerance.
You can't treat all
ideas as equally good.
The question is will Silicon
Valley last, you know.
And that's something I discovered
about these golden ages is
that don't last that long.
They're very fragile.
Like, there's one element in the
periodic table, I forget its name,
but it's so unstable it lasts about
ten second and then poof it's gone.
And these golden ages
are almost like that.
Because there are these
goldilock places where they need
to achieve this sweet spot and
it's very hard to maintain.
And that tension I talked about,
that sort of chaos that drives it,
can ultimately can tear it apart.
And I conclude that really
what leads to the demise
of these places is really
one word, arrogance.
They become arrogant.
And if you're arrogant,
you're not ignorant.
And if you're not ignorant,
you're not going
to produce anything worthwhile.
You need to know what
you don't know.
You need to know the
unknown unknowns
as Donald Rumsfeld once said.
It really is important to maintain
that openness to experience.
So ancient Athens, you
know, becomes closed off.
They believe they have
all the answers
and then it starts to decline.
And you see this time and
again happening with places.
So my advice to Silicon Valley was
to -- would be to remain open minded
and to really, I -- in the
conclusion of the book,
I always wrestle with this.
Like -- I'm not someone
who really --
I'm really in my element when
it comes to contradictions.
I really relish contradictions
and trying
to hold two contradictory ideas
in my head at the same time
without my head exploding.
But there is a -- I'm
just being honest here --
a pressure to tie things
up in a neat bow.
People want to know
what the answer is.
Like what is the special
sauce that if you were going
to create a Silicon Valley or
an ancient Athens from zero,
like Frankenstein's
monster only in a good way,
you know, what would you do?
So I'm here to tell you
that if I knew that answer,
I'm here to tell you I would
not be here telling you.
I would be on a yacht in the
Mediterranean sipping a drink
with an umbrella in it because I
would be very, very wealthy; right?
And there have been all these
attempts to re-create Silicon Valley
and they all fail; right?
Because they're trying
to re-create a culture
and culture is more
organic than that.
Having said that I do provide the
three D's at the end with a bonus,
fourth D thrown in no extra charge.
And this is what I think
these places have in common.
No. 1 is diversity.
Diversity not only ethnically.
In fact, I wouldn't even say ethnic
diversity is the most important kind
of diversity I'm talking about.
But intellectual diversity.
I mean a lot of different
ideas, having that tolerance
and that openness to other ideas.
And the second D is
discernment; right?
So you've got this openness,
you're letting everything in,
but you're discerning
and you're willing to --
I believe it was poet Allen
Ginsberg kill your darlings,
you know, brutally.
Make it look like an accident
if you have to but, you know.
But you need to separate the
good ideas from the bad ideas.
The third D is disorder which
makes some people uncomfortable
because they think,
well, we need order.
We need -- we need to
have things just working
in a certain way especially
corporations.
We need a system.
But, in fact, there's always that
element of disorder and even chaos
if you will because a chaotic
setting you're getting lots
of sensory input.
You have lots of say
molecules bouncing off
of each other in a small space.
They're more likely to
form new combinations.
That's why one of the reasons
why density is important
for creative places.
Not density alone because
prisons are dense places
but not particularly creative.
No, seriously.
And I think it's actually
more nuance.
I think you need density and
you need trust of one another.
You need intimacy in the
best sense of the word.
And in these places, these
genius clusters you had people,
fellow geniuses, co-geniuses who
were intimate with each other
who were competitive
but in a healthy way.
And the bonus D because really
everything has to be in three's.
Like top three ways, no
one ever has top four.
But I realize the bonus
D is discomfort; right?
You need to be a little
bit uncomfortable.
You need to be challenged.
Most geniuses come from the
middle and upper middle classes,
not from the aristocracy.
I hope I've given you
something to think about,
made you a little bit uncomfortable,
but not too uncomfortable.
And with that I welcome your
questions about anything at all.
[ Applause ]
We have microphones I believe.
Oh, yes?
>> Hi.
>> Eric Weiner: Hi.
>> I think it's on, yeah.
I think you were beginning, you were
alluding to where my question here.
In the actual geography
of the places was there
anything you discerned,
I mean you talked about
density but --
>> Eric Weiner: Right.
>> had actual --
>> Eric Weiner: As far as
like topography, you know,
which I do look at, you know, like
I arrived in Athens and, you know,
the light strikes you immediately.
It's very stark and
beautiful, brilliant light.
And that somehow make a difference.
But then you think of what
about Elizabethan London?
That's dreary and it
produced Shakespeare.
So just as in geography unless
I can include, you know,
weather doesn't explain happiness.
I don't think that
climate explains genius.
You can be a genius in a
rainy place or a sunny place.
But I think the role
that topography, say,
played in ancient Athens,
is that, you know,
the rocky hilly terrain sort
of cut off these city
states from one another.
So it allowed that -- those
different Petri dishes to grow
and I think that was very important.
And people can be inspired
by landscape, you know.
And they can go out into the desert
to have their creative epiphany.
But they always will
return to a city, you know,
like Beethoven would go off for
these walks in the Wienerwald,
the woods, outside of Vienna and
got a lot of his ideas there.
But he always returned to the city
because that's where
his audience was.
That's where his patrons were.
And so I've noticed that there's
always this toggling, you know,
between countryside and the
city, between being very,
you know, social and being low.
David Hume, the Scottish
philosopher,
he'd do these mind experiments
for days at a time just staying
in his apartment, not
leaving, you know, in his head.
But then he would write about how he
desperately needed to get to the pub
and have a stiff drink
and socialize with people.
And so I think geniuses
are very good at toggling.
Thank you.
>> I don't know -- oh, there it is.
I was wondering if you had any
thoughts about Richard Florida
and the creative class and the
idea that in some of his writings
and the idea that people
are choosing to live --
smart, creative people are
choosing to live in environments
that are supporting of that.
So that's sort of kind of more an
American focus, current focus --
>> Eric Weiner: Right.
Yeah.
>> That's my first question.
And the second question is you
are in Washington after all
and I was wondering if
you have contemplated
and perhaps this is oxymoron but
is there anything you might say
about the creation of genius
in government [laughter].
>> Eric Weiner: Gene -- government.
>> Thank you.
>> Eric Weiner: I'm familiar
with Richard Florida's ideas
and I think some of
them are quite good.
I think he's right
about urban density
but I think his explanation is
incomplete because it misses
that intimacy I talked about.
I think the creative class
is true up to a point.
There are creative people who are
attracted to certain environments.
But what I think he misses
is that discomfort part
that by the time places become
nice enough, in quotes, nice,
to attract creative people,
they're no longer creative.
Thus the exodus from say Soho
to Brooklyn to maybe Queens
or who knows where -- what's
happening in New York now.
You know, it's one
thing to say, okay,
to have nice sushi restaurants,
the ethnic restaurants,
and some theater, but creative
people are creating that.
They're not drawn necessarily to
something that exists already.
I think he underestimates the
role of a challenge that you --
that on the cusp when you know
now I guess it's hip to live
in Williamsburg, Brooklyn
but for a while it was edgy.
And so those people were not
necessarily following Richard
Florida's rule of the creative
class being drawn to the bon bons --
that these cultural bon bons
that these places offer.
I think creative people
are motivated
by a challenge more
than by nice things.
The tolerance part he's
right about, though.
Yes?
>> Hi. Thank you for your time.
I was hoping to learn a little
bit more about your thoughts
on gentrification and how that
impacts the genius of a place.
It seems really relevant
to the Silicon Valley
and during what's happened there.
And I'm wondering if
you've learned anything
about places being either more
or less successful
from confronting that.
I'm just curious how that came up.
>> Eric Weiner: Well, I
think just to follow it,
it sort of relates to
that question a bit.
That once a place becomes
gentrified,
it becomes less challenging.
And, of course, you price out people
who might be truly
creative which is a problem.
You know, another part of the
question -- can you say that again?
>> I don't know if
there's any examples
from your historical study
of -- addressing that.
>> Eric Weiner: Right.
I would say that something
really interesting
from say ancient Athens
is that, you know,
I was just leaving no stone unturned
so I looked into the possibility
of food as an excuse to eat too.
Like, you know, was it the
diet -- stay with me on this.
Was it the diet, the
ancient Greek diet
that maybe explained their genius.
So it turns out there's
this restaurant
in Athens called Archaion Gefseis
which means ancient flavors.
And they create this atmosphere
where it's just like you're
in 400 BC and you're
eating just the food then.
Like so they didn't have
tomatoes; there's no tomato.
They didn't have forks.
They had knives and spoons so
you only had knives and spoons.
You know, I believe the restaurant
does take credit cards so, you know.
But it turns out the
food was really bad.
It was really plain and simple.
They are just not foodies.
And then something happened and
they became foodies and they started
to really get into that
decadent foodie culture.
And you can -- I'm not saying
there's a causation here.
But there is a correlation between
the Athenians becoming foodies
and the decline of
their civilization.
So I think once places
become over-gentrified
and become a bit silly if I can
say that that way, then, you know,
your energy's going into finding
just the perfect olive oil,
you know, as opposed to
thinking about other stuff.
So gentrification is
too dangerous I think.
Yes?
>> Hi. Do you believe that every
civilization has its cluster
of geniuses?
And if so, how did,
for your research,
how did you choose one civilization
or golden age over another?
>> Eric Weiner: That's
a really good question.
Does every -- you know
I'd have to --
I realize this is not a
very Washington thing to say
but I don't know whether
every civilization had one.
I do know that many,
many do and did.
And I do know that my
process of whittling it down
and choosing these were
very -- was very difficult.
I had considered, seriously
considered a chapter on the Arab
and Muslim golden age which spanned
actually more centuries than most
and spanned, you know,
geographically, you know,
from Morocco to Persia and
probably further east than that.
The sort of epicenters of
the place though that, again,
that I'm traveling for this book
were Baghdad and the House of Wisdom
in 800 AD in Damascus and although
I'm a former foreign correspondent I
was not prepared to go to
those places at this time.
I did not want my obituary
to read Author dies while
researching book on genius.
So but seriously I was very --
I felt very bad that I was
not able to include that.
I had toyed with including a
chapter on Paris of the 1920s.
But Woody Allen's movie, Midnight
in Paris, had just come out.
I thought it was overly familiar.
But I came to regret that decision.
True story.
I get a call from -- because
the book's been translated
into some 16 languages
but not French.
And I got a call from the French
publisher says Mr. Weiner,
we like your book.
It's very nice.
We would like to publish
it here in France
but why you don't have a
chapter on the French geniuses.
We have so many.
That stung.
So there a lots of places
I could have included.
I tried to go with a cross
section geographically,
temporally across time, and
in terms of familiarity.
Good question.
>> Thank you.
>> Eric Weiner: Yes?
>> Hi. This is a rather
trivial question.
Have you ever --
>> Eric Weiner: There
are no trivial questions.
>> Oh, okay.
Have you ever watched the
series, Silicon Valley?
>> Eric Weiner: Oh, this is trivial.
>> And if so, -- and if so, do
you have any thoughts about it?
>> Eric Weiner: I have watched it.
I met one of the guys,
not who stars in it
but who's a venture capitalist named
Roger McNamee who appears in my book
and who was consulted with -- by
the producers of it, you know.
And who makes this sort of
cameo appearance in the series.
And he thought it was spot on.
And I think it -- it
does a good job of sort
of puncturing the myth
around it; right?
And one of those myths is
that Silicon Valley
embraces failure; right.
This failure fetish.
Failure is good, you know.
In early Silicon Valley,
pioneers said well,
if you fail in Silicon Valley
out here in the West, you know,
far away from the East Coast,
your neighbors won't --
your family won't know and your
neighbors won't care, you know.
That kind of freedom.
And there is some truth to that.
But really if you think about,
if you think about a Steve Jobs
and his back story, we love
the back story of the failures
because it ultimately
led to success; right?
And, in fact, as one
anthropologist points out to me,
if you fail in Silicon
Valley, you're working
with a pretty big net, you know,
because you can work again.
These other places I
looked at if you fail,
like in renaissance
Florence, you were done.
You know, the stakes were higher.
So the show's pretty good,
I think, at, you know,
it does what all good satire does.
It exaggerates a bit, probably not
as much as we think to make a point.
And it exaggerates
the culture in order
to illuminate the culture
of Silicon Valley.
So yeah and it's funny.
Don't forget that.
Not trivial at all.
>> Hi. I was just wondering if
you had any tips for application
for those of us who might find
ourselves in jobs that are
like somewhat bureaucratic
or limited
by like working within a system.
Did you find any tips
within your research --
>> Eric Weiner: Which reminds me,
I never answered the
government question.
I'm going to answer that
one and then answer yours.
I did not include Washington,
D.C. even though I live here.
I don't think -- this has
probably not been a place of genius
for a good couple hundred
years to be honest.
I think because of the caution
that comes with bureaucracy.
You mentioned being sort of -- if
you're stuck in a bureaucratic job
or you're stuck somewhere,
you know, bureaucracy
and creativity are
pretty antithetical
because of the cautiousness.
There have been certainly --
well, institutions you can
say that have produced things.
The Manhattan Project
was a group that was part
of the federal government,
right, but it was in New Mexico.
They got them the hell
out of Washington
and said go to New Mexico.
And Bell Labs while not
government was a corporation
that produced lots
of creative places.
I think what the things you
can do and this is sort of one
of the points in my
book is that, you know,
we don't need an ancient
Florence or anything like that.
But the thing -- there
are lessons --
this is [inaudible]
with things you can use
to be less miserable in your job.
One, is you can go for a walk.
Can you get out of your office?
If you can that's good, okay.
Because lots of geniuses
have walked.
Beethoven was a walker, Freud was a
walker, other people were walkers.
There's something about walking
that's very conducive to creativity.
Go to a coffee shop if you can.
Because there's the
ideal decibel level,
research shows, for
creative thinking.
It's not complete silence and
it's not really loud noises.
It's about 70 decibels,
that background din.
I'm convinced this
is one of the keys
to Starbucks success,
that background din.
And also you can engage in some
creative thinking exercises,
you know, such as what's
called homeopathic thinking,
taking two contradictory ideas
and juxtaposing them
and things like that.
But I would caution you and
this is sort of the whole point
of my book is that I think a lot of
this creativity training that goes
on in corporations and institutions
is not that helpful if the people
at the top are not open
to these new ideas.
You need someone at
the top who's going
to say yes, let's run with that.
Otherwise, you can have all
the creative thinking exercises
in the world and you're
just going to have a lot
of frustrated creative employees.
And on that kind of downer
of a note, I'm going to have
to say thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.